nathan was a financial advisor in
minneapolis
to adults help them do budgeting things
like that and one day he got contacted
by the school
in a middle class neighbor not
particularly fancy neighborhood
saying look we got a problem the kids in
their school
were demanding really expensive consumer
objects like
nike sneakers and they were getting
extremely distressed when they didn't
get them
and it was freaking out the school is
freaking out the parents are like what
can we do
and they asked him to come in and do
what he did which was give budgeting
advice so he comes in to advise the kids
on budgeting and quite quickly realizes
this ain't a budgeting issue right
there's something deeper going on here
so he starts to work with the uh he did
this interesting experiment was then
monitored
so set up with professor castle that was
monitored so what they did is they would
get
teenagers and their parents to come they
would meet in groups
i think it was once a fortnight for six
months something like that
and at first the first day the very
first session
the teenagers and parents had to write
down what they thought they
had to have right an initial course
people would initially say food and
shelter and
perfectly sensible things and quite
quickly the teenagers would say i gotta
have you know whatever the latest
designer object was
and and then they would say tell me what
you would
feel if you got those objects if you got
that thing
and quite quickly the tina quite quickly
it was clearly not about
an inherent property of the consumer
objects it's social acceptance it's
where you fall
in the social pecking order and it
didn't take long
for the kids to articulate what you're
saying
for them to go huh why do i think that
right you they didn't need much
prompting as the sessions went on
so where did you get the idea that you
will have value as an individual
if you have this lump of shitty right
from the 8 000
commercials and billboards that i've
seen in the last 24 hours
exactly so they would firstly what they
did was work on
seeing well where did those junk values
come from they would look at the ads
everyone likes to think they're smarter
than the ad
and everyone began to realize oh [ __ ]
the ad got me right but then they did it
what i thought was the more interesting
bit
they began to say okay well set that
stuff aside
what do you actually value what do you
think is actually important
in life and they started writing about
that they started discussing it in
groups we don't really have those
conversations very often in our culture
certainly much less than we have
conversations about shopping
um and they started talking about what
they actually thought was important what
actually gave them joy in their life
someone talked about playing music
someone talked about just love
there was a whole range of things living
in the natural world
and they started about how could you
build more of that stuff into your life
and lesser the junk
and they started to do it and this was
monitored over time and what it found
was just this intervention
and meeting once a fortnight led to a
really significant shift in people's
values
what this tells us professor cassar
argues i think persuasively
is these insights are just below the
surface right um
this is not like explaining quantum
physics or
complex linguistics or something
in some ways these are almost banal
insights and yet
the reason they have to be stated and
argued for
is because we've created a culture
that's all about getting us to not see
them
it's a machine that in fact faces real
challenges if we stop buying crap
right the problem is if we carry on
buying the crap and thinking that's what
life is about
we have the crisis not that system so i
think it's about
and you can see again i really touched
on a few of the causes obviously that i
talk about lost connections but
you can see again this is a very
different story
than telling someone there's just a
chemical missing in your brain and all
you need to do is drug yourself
right it leads to a different
set of attempted solutions and i believe
very strongly in antidepressants in the
sense that
people are really depressed they're not
making it up they're not imagining it
they are terribly depressed and anxious
they need solutions to that but what i
argue is we need to expand our concept
of what antidepressants are
for some people one of the things on the
menu should remain chemical
antidepressants they have value
but we need a much broader range of
antipresence on the cow model right
that group that nathan and professor
casa led where they got people to talk
about their values and it shifted their
values over time
that's an antidepressant that gardening
program in east london
that was an antidepressant obviously the
last third of the book is about these
different kinds of
antidepressants they are just as real
and just as important
easily as the the kind of chemical
solutions because they're attending to
some of the other causes yeah yeah yeah
and and
i think we're seeing some interesting
cultural movements at the moment
that are kind of uh incarnations of what
you're talking about i mean this whole
minimalism thing uh that a lot of young
people
are super you know all about and keying
on
that didn't really exist even i don't
know five or ten years ago
now there's movies about it there's
movements there's youtube channels
there's people
with podcasts about this uh who are
basically speaking to gen z and saying
listen everything that you see all
around you
every single day is promising you a lie
the answers that you seek will not be
found
you know in these in this material way i
think that's true and i think it's
interesting this is playing out with
teenagers so much because
um the figures for teenage distress are
really shocking
yeah i mean what are they they're super
high they're exceptional there's a
varying
apart promise it's difficult to measure
distress over time because
some of the figures that show
astronomical increases i think are
slightly misleading because there's been
a decline in stigma of talking about it
so that would mean that more people for
example my grandmother i'm sure from
having discussed this with her
while she was alive um was terribly
depressed in her 30s and 40s
if anyone had ever asked her are you
depressed she would have said no and she
would never agree to go to the doctor
so there's been whereas it would you
know if um
you know a relative of mine the same age
now does they would they would say yes
and they would get help
uh they would go to the doctor for help
so i think the kind of
stratospheric figures for increase are
misleading but i do think there's good
evidence there has been
a significant increase um we know
teenage suicide for example has gone up
which is obviously a very relatively
easy way of measuring
extreme distress but i want to think
about obviously one of the factors we
think about when we talk about teenagers
is social media and so on i want to
think about this
one places that really helped me to
understand is i went to the first ever
internet rehab center in the united
states oh wow
there's something like that exists it's
glad it does it should exist
it's in spokane it's just outside
spokane in washington
and i remember when i arrived there i
remember
getting out the car and absolutely
instinctively looking at my phone and
being really pissed off there was no
reception to check my email i was like
oh wait you're in there where are you
what is this place
um i'm going in there no wi-fi it was
hell what can i say but i remember going
in there and talking to these
the so they get also kind of this place
called restart washington they get all
kinds of people at restart washington
but they disproportionately get
young men who become obsessed with these
multiplayer role play games like world
of warcraft or fortnite
or therefore i didn't exist at the time
that i was there it's become an issue
for them
since i'm sure um and
speaking of these young men i was i felt
like i was getting this kind of insight
and then
i spoke to dr hilary cash who who runs
the co-runs the place
i was a great person and she really
helped me to understand it
so she said to me something like you've
got to ask yourself
what are these young men getting out of
these games they're getting the things
they used to get from the culture but
they no longer get
um so what do they get
they get a sense of tribe and identity
they get a sense of status and a way
they can gain status that they can feel
they're good at something
and they get a sense they're physically
roaming around the average
child in britain now spends less time
outdoors than the average maximum
security prisoner
because by law a maximum security
prisoner has to have 70 minutes a day
and most of our kids don't get that um
but what they're getting is like a kind
of parody of those things
right i began to think as i was speaking
to her and the young men there
the relationship between social media
and social life
is a bit like the relationship between
porn and sex
right i'm not anti-porn but if your
entire sex life consists of looking at
porn
you're going to be going around pissed
off and irritated the whole time because
you didn't evolve to masturbate over a
screen you're evolved to have sex
in the same way um there's a place for
screen-based interaction of course i'm
not some weird luddite
but that's not what we evolved to have
if you and i were having this
conversation over skype
i wouldn't feel you were hearing me and
you wouldn't feel you were hearing no
the other way around in the way that we
feel we're hearing and seeing each other
now
right um what happens is
the internet arrives and it looks a lot
like the things we've lost
right you've lost friends here's a whole
range of facebook friends you've lost
status
do as many status updates as you want
right
but again it's it's like a parody of the
thing we've lost
and the expert on loneliness professor
john cassiopo said to me gave me a good
kind of rule of thumb
which is if you're turning to the
internet as a way station to meet people
offline
great if it's the last destination on
the line generally something's gone
wrong
so
[Music]
you